Ça vous dirait une petite bière ?
À consommer avec modération.
Chaque année, les Français en consomment
30 litres en moyenne par personne.
51% d'entre eux la préfèrent même au vin.
Et si aujourd'hui,
on fabriquait notre propre bière ?
Suivez-moi.
Je connais un endroit où l'on ne brasse
pas que de l'air, mais de la bière.
Mais auparavant,
un petit tour par l'atelier !
Depuis quelques années,
la France connaît un véritable boom
de la bière artisanale.
Avec 2500 brasseries, c'est même
le pays d'Europe qui en compte le plus.
Mais avant de nous lancer
dans le brassage, c'est le terme consacré,
un petit retour en arrière :
qui a inventé la bière ?
De l'eau, de l'orge,
du houblon, de la levure.
Voilà les 4 ingrédients à partir
desquels on fabrique la bière
depuis la nuit des temps.
Car sa consommation ne date pas d'hier.
Il y a quelques années, des archéologues
ont découvert, dans une grotte en Israël,
3 récipients contenant des traces de bière
vieilles de 13000 ans.
Les Égyptiens aussi en fabriquaient
et lui accordaient une grande valeur.
Les ouvriers qui construisaient
les pyramides recevaient
5 litres de bière par jour.
Faut-il en déduire que sans la bière,
les pyramides de Gizeh n'existeraient pas ?
Au Moyen-Âge, c'est une boisson
très appréciée en Europe.
Ce sont les moines qui la brassent.
Ils sont passés
maîtres dans l'art du brassage
depuis que Charlemagne leur en a confié
le monopole.
D'où l'appellation : bière d’abbaye.
Pas étonnant que certains la boivent
religieusement.
À noter que les moines bénédictins
de Saint-Wandrille, en Normandie,
sont actuellement les seuls en France
qui continuent de brasser dans l'enceinte
d'une abbaye.
La consommation mondiale de bière s'élève
à environ 2 milliards d'hectolitres
par an, soit l'équivalent de 6500 litres
de bière par seconde !
Et contre toute attente,
les plus gros producteurs
ne sont pas les Allemands,
mais les Chinois.
Quant aux plus grands buveurs, là
encore, ce ne sont pas les Allemands,
ni les Belges, d'ailleurs,
ce sont les Tchèques.
150 litres par an et par personne,
5 fois plus que les Français.
Mais je vous rassure,
on n'a pas à avoir honte.
En mai dernier,
le tout premier marathon de la bière
a eu lieu chez nous, à Montbrison,
dans la Loire.
Plus de 3000 personnes y ont participé.
En guise de ravitaillement, de l'eau
et je vous le donne en mille, de la bière.
Qui franchement,
n'est pas du tout conseillée pour étancher
notre soif quand on est en plein effort.
Dans ce cas, mieux vaut privilégier
la bière sans alcool.
Enfin, sans alcool,
en réalité, ces boissons en contiennent,
mais à un taux infime
qui se situe autour de 0,4%,
contre 4 à 6% en moyenne
pour les bières classiques.
Cette quantité n'est pas suffisante
pour avoir des effets néfastes
sur l'organisme.
La composition de la bière sans alcool
ainsi que son processus de fabrication
sont les mêmes
que ceux d'une bière classique,
mais une étape est rajoutée pour enlever
l'alcool présent dans la boisson.
Bon, allez, assez de théorie,
on passe à la pratique !
Elle ne va pas se faire toute seule,
cette bière épicurieuse !
J'ai rendez-vous avec
Florian Namias, brasseur de son état.
Je suis à Paris,
dans le quartier de Ménilmontant,
tout près du Père-Lachaise,
et je me dirige vers un pub
qui sert de la bière maison
entièrement fabriquée sur place.
Bon, c'est un peu tôt.
On vient ici non seulement
pour déguster la bière, mais pour voir
car tout se passe sous les yeux
des clients.
Bonjour Florian.
Salut Jamy !
Merci de m'accueillir dans ce magnifique
endroit, cet espace complètement ouvert
où l'on déguste de la bière
et où on la brasse en même temps.
Et j'adore cette déco.
Enfin, je parle de déco, c'est
surtout du matériel pour brasser la bière.
Oui, ce sont des outils de travail.
Ils servent à brasser.
Nos cuves pour le brassage.
Après, on a des fermenteurs dans le fond,
tu les verras tout à l'heure,
et au plafond, 11 cuves de service
pour servir la bière
directement à la pression.
Vous produisez quel volume de bière ici ?
On fait des brassins de 500 litres.
Un brassin c'est ça.
C'est une fabrication
et on fait 1 à 2 brassins par semaine.
Ça nous fait grosso
modo 35000 litres par an.
Bon, je ne voudrais pas te mettre la pression,
mais on a quand même une bière
à brasser.
C'est parti !
Je te suis !
Alors premier ingrédient pour faire de
la bière : l'orge qui est à mes pieds.
Alors ce ne sont pas des grains
exactement
comme ceux que l'on prélève sur un épi.
Ces grains ont déjà été
un peu transformés.
Effectivement, c'est du malt d'orge.
Donc c'est de l'orge qui a été trempée.
Puis on a fait germer l'orge
et il a été séché.
Donc ça a réveillé la graine.
Ça permet de libérer le sucre
qui est à l'intérieur
et ça va lui donner de la saveur
et de la couleur avec le séchage.
Alors juste à côté,
il y a d'autres grains.
C'est de l'orge, je suppose,
mais c'est pas de la même couleur.
C'est toujours du malt d'orge. En fait,
tout simplement,
il est plus séché,
donc il va commencer à caraméliser.
Ça va donner encore plus d'arômes,
encore plus de goût.
Pour une bière ambrée,
on va utiliser des malts caramélisés
et si on veut faire une bière noire, on utilise par
exemple du malt noir en petite quantité.
Mais aujourd'hui,
je te propose qu'on fasse une bière plus
légère, rafraîchissante, sans malt noir.
On va faire une bière de style Gose,
une bière de type allemand de Leipzig.
Et on va mélanger du malt d'orge blond
avec du blé
pour donner un côté plutôt blanche.
Et donc ça, c'est le blé,
mais ça n'a pas du tout la même tête !
Lui, il est en flocons,
il n'a pas été malté.
OK, bon, on y va.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait de tout ça maintenant ?
Le malt d'orge, il faut le concasser.
Donc on va aller à la machine qui est là,
le moulin à malt, pour le faire.
Très bien !
L'idée, c'est de concasser le malt
en une farine grossière,
en gardant les petites enveloppes intactes
pour nous aider à la filtration du malt
que tu verras après.
Je te laisse l'honneur, vas-y !
Très bien. Oui, on peut appeler ça un honneur.
Et là, je verse directement dedans ?
- Alors tu verses tout, vas-y.
- OK
Tu peux poser le sac par dessus.
C'est bon pour toi ? On est prêt ?
C’est bon pour moi.
Ça fait du bruit quand même !
Et voilà ! Ouf !
Alors effectivement, ça se voit
déjà à l'œil, mais au toucher,
c'est pas de la farine.
On voit que c'est concassé,
que c'est grossier même si
il y a quand même
un peu de farine au milieu.
Alors ça, je te propose qu'on le prenne,
on l'emmène là-bas le mettre dans la cuve
d’empâtage avec le blé, on va le mélanger.
OK, c'est parti et hop !
Il y a déjà de l'eau. Quel volume ?
400 litres.
Et donc on va verser le malt concassé
dans cette eau.
C'est parti, à toi l'honneur !
Comment s'appelle cette étape ?
C'est l’empâtage.
On va mélanger les céréales
pendant 1 h environ à 67 degrés.
Et toi,
pendant ce temps là, tu ne fais rien ?
Moi, je vais remuer.
Je vais remuer avec un fourquet.
- Tu vas brasser, en fait ?
- Je vais brasser.
Donc le fourquet, c'est
un peu comme une fourche
avec lequel on remue le grain pour
pas qu’il y ait de grumeau.
Je peux essayer pour voir
juste ce que ça donne ?
Sauf si là, on est à un moment délicat.
- Vas-y !
- OK
Il faut avoir de bons bras.
Essaie d’attaquer les paquets de grumeaux.
Quand j'étais petit,
on m'appelait comme ça, Jamy Grumeau.
On ajoute le blé ?
Allez, on y va.
J'y vais là ?
Vas-y. Hop.
On va mettre combien de malt concassé ?
Là, on est parti sur 50 kilos de malt
et 50 kilos de blé.
OK.
C'est sportif !
Ça m'apprendra, d'être curieux !
- On échange ?
- Allez, on échange !
Là, on veut faire un jus de céréales,
bien extraire
le sucre et l'amidon
qui se trouvent dans la céréale.
L'amidon qui est aussi un sucre,
parce que c'est la fermentation,
donc de ces sucres,
qui va produire l'alcool
que l'on trouve à l'intérieur de la bière.
Et à ce stade, ces sucres forment
des molécules longues,
trop longues
pour pouvoir être transformées
en alcool par les levures
qu'on ajoutera un peu plus tard.
Donc il faut réduire ces molécules
et on va confier ce travail à des enzymes,
d'autres molécules qui sont
naturellement présentes sur le malt.
Ce sont elles qui vont tenir les ciseaux.
Et pour qu'elles travaillent,
il leur faut un peu de chaleur.
C'est pour cette raison
qu'on a fait chauffer l'eau.
On est à quelle température ?
Là, on est à 67 degrés
et on va laisser comme ça pendant 1 h.
- OK, je remets le couvercle ?
- C'est parti.
Au boulot les enzymes !
C'est un truc de glandeur le brassage !
J’aurais pas dû jouer ça.
Et voilà, ça fait 1 h.
L’empâtage est terminé.
- Je peux goûter alors ?
- On peut goûter si tu veux.
Franchement, ça n'a pas le goût de bière.
C'est normal,
la fermentation n'a pas commencé
et il manque un ingrédient essentiel :
le houblon.
Ah ! Le houblon.
Et une fois séché, ça ressemble à ça.
C'est en quelque sorte
l'épice du brasseur.
En Alsace, où il est beaucoup cultivé,
on le surnomme l'or vert.
C'est cette plante qui apporte des arômes
et de l'amertume à la bière.
Comme pour la vigne, il existe de
très nombreuses variétés de houblon
en fonction des terroirs,
avec des centaines d'arômes différents
et donc autant de saveurs de bière
possibles.
L'IPA, par exemple, l'India
Pale Ale, une bière d'origine anglaise
qui a été remise au goût du jour
il y a peu, contient en moyenne
deux fois plus de houblon
que les autres bières.
C'est ce qui lui donne
ce goût très prononcé.
Mais ce n'est pas tout.
Cette plante a d'autres avantages.
Elle permet de mieux conserver la bière
grâce à ses propriétés antiseptiques.
C'est aussi un excellent diurétique.
Vous l'avez compris, il favorise
l'élimination de l'eau par les reins.
C'est pour cette raison
qu'on a souvent envie de faire pipi
quand on boit de la bière.
Bon, c'est pas tout,
mais moi, j'ai une envie pressante de voir
à quoi ressemble cette bière épicurieuse !
Donc ça, c'est notre houblon,
c'est du houblon en pellets qu'on utilise.
Je peux toucher ?
Bien sûr, et puis sentir.
Hmmm. Ah, ça sent bon !
Et là, effectivement, ça sent la bière,
ça sent même l'IPA.
Donc là, on va le mettre
dans la cuve d'ébullition, dans le moût
pendant 1 h pour infuser pour qu'il
donne son amertume.
OK, c'est parti.
Et donc le moût est transféré dans ces cuves ?
Voilà, on est en train de transférer le moût
dans les fermenteurs et c'est là qu'on va
pouvoir ajouter la levure.
Je t'en ai mis un peu ici.
- C'est ça ?
- Oui.
On croirait un milkshake !
Bon, c'est pas très ragoûtant, mais c'est
la même chose qui est dans le pain
et sans ça, on ne peut pas avoir d'alcool.
Mais une fois qu'on aura mis cette levure,
ça y est, on aura tous nos ingrédients et
on pourra déguster notre bière ?
Non, il va falloir que la levure travaille
pendant environ quinze jours
pour qu'elle transforme le sucre en alcool.
Et après, si on en a envie,
on peut rajouter des épices.
En l'occurrence, pour la bière
qu'on fait aujourd'hui,
je te propose qu'on
rajoute des graines de coriandre
et des fleurs d'hibiscus qui vont apporter
de la fraîcheur et du fruité.
À partir de ce moment-là,
on va pouvoir déguster notre bière ?
Il faut que les épices infusent
et qu'il y ait une phase de garde
pour que la bière s'affine.
- Donc il faut encore attendre un mois.
- Il faut être patient !
Alors si je fais les comptes,
quinze jours de fermentation
pour la levure
et puis encore un mois de maturation
avec les épices,
ça nous fait un mois et demi.
Je vous rassure, on ne va pas attendre
tout ce temps pour déguster notre bière.
- Je crois que t'avais prévu le coup ?
- Elle est déjà à la carte !
- On va la déguster ?
- C'est parti !
Je te suis.
- Qu'est-ce que je te sers ?
- Eh bien,
une épicurieuse !
Une épicurieuse, c'est parti.
Avec juste ce qu'il faut de mousse.
Et voilà.
Merci beaucoup.
En fait, cette mousse,
elle se forme grâce au gaz
carbonique qui est dissout dans la bière.
Au moment où il remonte,
il forme des bulles qui vont embarquer
des protéines
qui sont contenues dans la bière
et qui proviennent,
souvenez vous, du malt.
Et donc c'est cette matière
qui va former cette mousse un peu épaisse
qui, au final, est très utile,
surtout quand on boit la bière lentement
comme je le fais.
Vous le voyez, la mousse forme
une barrière qui va piéger les arômes.
Du coup, la bière reste savoureuse
tout au long de sa consommation.
- On trinque ?
- C'est parti !
Et à la vôtre !
Voilà chers épicurieuses et épicurieux,
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu.
Si vous passez du côté de Ménilmontant,
venez goûter
l'épicurieuse, c'est aussi votre bière.
N'hésitez pas à liker
et à nous dire en commentaire
ce que vous avez pensé de cette vidéo,
sans modération cette fois !
À très bientôt !